let me then for the first opening
statement invite to the podium Sean
Carroll thank you thanks everyone for
being here before getting into the
debate ii part of the debate i wanted to
recognize that while it's absolutely
true that we disagree the two sides of
the debate we have things that are very
very important that should be clarified
upon which we have very very different
points of view it's also true that we
come here for similar reasons we share
concerns we're asking the same kinds of
questions what is the fundamental nature
of reality what is humankind's role in
the cosmos and this is why I will always
remain stubbornly optimistic that
through discussion and reason and
rationality we can actually make
progress towards at least understanding
if not agreement which is why I love
debates like this I think that they are
a very good thing to have
having said that religion and science
have gone their separate ways over the
years 500 years ago this debate would
not have been held there was no
demarcation between what we would now
call science and what we would call
religion there was just attempts to
understand the world and what happened
is that science came about by developing
techniques methodologies for gaining
reliable knowledge about the world and
the reliable reliable knowledge that we
got was incompatible with some of the
presuppositions of religious belief the
basic thing that we learned by doing
science for 400 years is something
called naturalism the idea that there is
only one reality that there are not
separate planes of the natural and the
supernatural that there is only one
material existence and we are part of
the universe we do not stand outside of
it in any way and the way that science
got there is through basically realizing
that human beings are not that smart
you are not volkens you're not mr. Spock
you're not perfectly logical we as human
beings are subject to all sorts of
biases and cognitive shortcomings we
tend to be wishful thinkers and to see
patterns where they're not there and so
and in response to this science
developed techniques for giving
ourselves reality checks for not letting
us believe things that the evidence does
not stand up to one technique is simply
skepticism which you may have heard of
scientists are taught that we should be
our own theories harshest critics
scientists spend all their time trying
to disprove their favourite ideas this
is a remarkable way of doing things that
is a little bit counterintuitive but
helps us resist the lure of wishful
thinking the other technique is
empiricism we realize that we are not
smart enough to get true knowledge about
the world just by thinking about it
we have to go out there and look at the
world and what we've done by this for
last 400 years is to realize that human
beings are not separate that the world
is one thing the natural world and it
can be understood this is very
counterintuitive it's not at all obvious
this naturalism claim
when you talk to a person they have
thoughts and feelings and responses when
you talk to a dead person a corpse
I'd be morbid here but you don't get
those same responses those same thoughts
and feelings it's very natural very
commonsensical to think that a living
person possesses something that a corpse
does not some sort of spirits some sort
of animating soul or life force but this
idea as it turns out does not stand up
to closer scrutiny and a big step
towards realizing this was made back in
the 1600s by a remarkable woman named
Princess Elizabeth of Bohemia they made
princesses differently back in the 17th
century
Elizabeth carried on a years-long
correspondence with Rene Descartes who
famously tried to develop a theory of
mind-body dualism and Elizabeth said I
don't understand what you're saying
because if you really believe that the
mind is in a separate realm from the
body my mind makes a choice to lift my
arm but it's my body that does it how
does the immaterial mind if you say
doesn't exist at a location in space how
does it act causally on the body how
does it interact with the stuff out of
which you are made and Descartes never
came up with a reliable believable
response to this objection of course
these days
the objection is enormous ly stronger we
would say you are made of atoms you are
made of cells which are made of
molecules which are made of atoms and as
physicists we know how atoms behave the
laws of physics governing the behavior
of atoms are completely understood you
put an atom in a certain set of
circumstances if you tell me those
circumstances are as a physicist I will
tell you what the atom will do if you
believe that the atoms that are inside
your brain in your body act differently
because they are in a living person than
if they are in a rock or a crystal then
what you're saying is that the laws of
physics are wrong that they need to be
altered because of the influence of a
spirit or a soul or something like that
that may be true science can't disprove
that but there is no evidence for it and
you getting much stronger explanatory
framework by assuming that it's just
atoms obeying the laws of physics that
kind of reasoning is a big step toward
naturalism another big step also
happened in the 1600s when Galileo came
upon the idea of conservation of
momentum and you might say why does
conservation of momentum get in the way
of my belief in the existence of God but
it does because before Galileo came
along physics was described by Aristotle
and Aristotle said something very again
something very obvious and common
sensical that if you want something to
keep moving you need to push it things
naturally come to rest left to their own
devices and but if you look at the world
you realize that things are moving all
over the place so Aristotle very
logically eventually concluded that you
need to invoke the existence of an
unmoved mover which can be identified of
course with God but then of course
Galileo comes along says actually the
natural behavior of matter is to keep
moving at a constant velocity motion is
perfectly natural when things stop it's
because you are acting on them through
friction or air resistance or
dissipation and then Isaac Newton comes
along and builds an elaborate edifice of
mechanics which explains the world
beautifully in purely material
principles and it's very very
interesting once that happened you
realize that the prime mover argument
doesn't work as well and you can
actually see a change in the theological
literature of
time before Newton and Galileo there was
emphasis put on ideas of prime movers
and first cause as argument from
cosmology and contingency and so forth
after Newton and Galileo the argument
emphasized something else the argument
from design people would say well sure
you can explain two planets moving
that's easy but all the life-forms the
marvelous diversity of life here on
earth that had to be made by some
guiding external intelligence in fact in
the 1700s money will con said there will
never be an Isaac Newton for a blade of
grass then of course in the 1800's we
got an Isaac Newton for a blade of grass
his name was Charles Darwin Darwin
showed how material matter all by itself
without guidance without purpose without
an aim just by the natural motion of
ordinary things can lead to the
marvelous diversity of organic life that
we see here on earth that was another
huge step in the direction of naturalism
now of course I could go on we could
talk about modern cosmology in the
origin of the universe we could talk
about neuroscience and what
consciousness is and so forth but I
don't want to do that right now we can
maybe talk about it later but I don't
want to do it right now basically
because it's kind of boring and the
reason why it's kind of boring is
because the argument is finished the
debate is over we've come to a
conclusion naturalism has won if you go
to any University Physics Department
listen to the talks they give her the
papers they write go to any biology
department go to any neuroscience
department any philosophy department
people whose professional job it is to
explain the world to come up with
explanatory frameworks that match what
we see no one mentions god there's never
an appeal to a supernatural realm like
people whose job it is to explain what
happens in the world everyone knows that
the naturalist explanations are the ones
that work and yet here we are we're
having a debate why are we having a
debate because clearly religion speaks
to people for reasons other than
explaining what happens in the world
most people who turn to religious belief
do not do so because they think it
provides the best theory of cosmology or
biology they turn to religious belief
because it provides them with purpose
and meaning in
their lives with a sense of right and
wrong with the community with hope so if
we want to say that science has refuted
religion we need to say that science has
something to say about those issues and
on that I have good news and bad news
for you the bad news is that the
universe does not care about you Clau
universe don't take up my time I'm in a
hurry here the universe is made of
elementary particles that don't have
intelligent don't pass judgment do not
have a sense of right and wrong and the
fear is the existential anxiety is that
if that purpose and meaningfulness is
not given to me by the universe then it
cannot exist the good news is that that
fear is a mistake but there is another
option that we create purpose and
meaning in the world if you love
somebody it is not because that love is
put into you by something outside it's
because you created that from inside
yourself if you act good to somebody
it's not because you're given
instructions to do so it's cuz that's a
choice that you made this is a very
scary world you should be affected at a
very deep level by the thought that the
universe doesn't care does not pass
judgment on you but it's also
challenging and liberating that we can
create lives that are worth living I've
never met God I've never met any spirits
or any angels but I've met human beings
many of them were amazing people and I
truly believe that if we accept the
universe for what it is if we approach
reality with an open mind and an open
heart then we can create lives very much
worth living
thank you